guten morgen
stellen sie sich vor sie betreten ihr
büro und plötzlich liegt dort ein
leibhaftiger löwe auf dem teppich oder
wie wäre es wenn ihre arbeitskollegen
auf einmal alle fenster aufreißen nur
kurz darauf frei wie vögel direkt gen
himmel zu entschwinden
in dem roman von sibylle lewitscharoff
verschwimmen die grenzen zwischen fakt
und fiktion wirklichkeit und wahn
diesseits und jenseits
warum das so ist und weshalb dieser
sprung in eine andere welt für uns
menschen so wichtig bleibt darf ich
heute mit einer der bedeutendsten
schriftstellerinnen unserer zeit
erörtern
frau der widerruf herzlich willkommen
dankeschön
lassen sie sich nicht mit einem zitat
aus ihrer feder beginnen sie schreiben
ein essay über die macht der
namensgebung beim namen gerufen sind wir
in der innersten substanz berührt die
uns zusammenhält
trifft das auch auf sie zu auf ihren
namen war ja heißen sie sibylle ja damit
habe ich ein wenig gehadert nicht mit
der bedeutung der sibylle die sehr
großartig sondern mit dem sibylle
lewitscharoff also lädle hintereinander
weg ist nicht so günstig also irgendein
27 vorname ohne lte anschluss wäre
besser gewesen
also es hat sie klang nicht gestört dass
er überschwänglich geführt aber sie
sagen die bedeutung der sibylle die pest
ganz passend das waren ja im antiken
griechenland profitieren die in
eigenwilliger reise von der zukunft
sprachen und auch die gegenwart deuteten
ihre großartige figuren natürlich auch
also sagen wir mal auch figuren von
einer gewissen weiblichen macht haben
sie verströmt weil er ein solches wissen
besitzt kann ja auch unheil stiften ja
also insofern ist es ein großer und auch
ein schöner name an sich nur eben mit
diesem nachnamen ist es nicht ganz so
geglückt finde ich und den nachnamen den
finde ich nun wirklich klasse
dann war ich immer stolz darauf aber
diese verbindung zwischen prophetie
zwischen der gabe dinge zu sagen und zu
sehen die andere nicht sehen und der
literatur besteht die für sie ja das ist
doppeldeutig also die gabe der prophetie
partner die gabe der prophetie habe ich
überhaupt nicht in politischen oder
realen dingen alles was ich mir je
vorgestellt habe in meinem leben
politisch ist vollkommen anders
eingetreten im guten wie im schlechten
also ich bin die schlechteste prophetin
aller zeiten
wenn es um politik geht aber natürlich
können sie in der literatur so etwas wie
visionen oder vorstellungswelten
erkunden die natürlich nicht der
realität entsprechen und das sie
berlinische wesen ist ja auch etwas was
sozusagen hörer seitz einen beistand
erfleht um auf den menschen wieder
einzuwirken also das ist nun tatsächlich
etwas was die literatur auch kann wenn
ihr vom höheren beistand und von den
namen sprechen dann gibt es gott der uns
den namen gibt aber eigentlich sind es
ja zunächst mal unsere eltern die es den
namen geben sie sind 954 in stuttgart
geboren als tochter eines bulgarischen
gynäkologen der dort praktizierte und
eine eingeborenen also eine schwäbin in
moderner verwaltungsfunktionen hätten
sie damit ja eigentlich einen
migrationshintergrund
ja hab ich schon aber das ist natürlich
ein bisschen lächerlich weil man
insofern weil mein vater sprach
hervorragend deutsch der hat eine
eigentlich große berufskarriere auch
gemacht der sprach besser als die
schwäbische verwandtschaft in der
eingeheiratet hat ein sehr sehr hoch
mögen des deut darum herum waren es
alles schwaben also es war eine sehr
große familie um die großmutter auch
herum das waren zwölf kinder mit einer
gewichtigen großtante luise die den
ganzen clan beherrschte und im zweiten
weltkrieg irgendwie schweinehälften nach
stuttgart transportierte und davon 24
häuser kauft also das heißt ich bin mit
sehr mächtigen schwäbinnen aufgewachsen
bei uns hatten die frauen in der familie
also in dritter generation auch große
macht also einerseits das tief
verankerte in der region andererseits
der vater aus der fremde hat das bei
ihnen schon früh eine art distanz und
auch im blick für das fremde des eigenen
bewirkt ja aber schwierig mein vater
hatte mit seinem vaterland er durfte
auch nicht zurück zwei diese
komplizierte geschichte das heißt ich
habe mir ich hab mein vater sehr geliebt
und mein vater war sehr französisch
orientiert davor als einer der ersten in
stuttgart einen sieht er als einen nicht
durch diese
die schöne leben also die schwarze kiste
gewesen und er war überhaupt sehr
französisch auch mit dem mittag kleidung
und so weiter orientiert und ich habe
mir immer gewünscht warum ist denn mein
vater um gottes willen kein franzose
wäre noch besser als garen
das hat damit zu tun dass er uns selber
ein so schwieriges verhältnis zum
heimatland hatte wenn ich noch eine
kleine geschichte beisteuern wird die
war auch extrem mein vater sprach gut
deutsch aber wenn er seine bulgarischen
kompagnons djk athleten zu besucht
hatten sprachen die bulgarisch und
unsere dackel das war ein wichtiges tor
meiner kindheit der verkroch sich sofort
unter dem sofa baller diese fremde
sprache irgendwie in ihre tiere und
nicht auch das ist ja ganz seltsam nicht
wahr wenn man menschen gut kennt die in
einer sprache sprechen und dann sprechen
sie eine andere sprache
dann sieht man einen anderen menschen
plötzlich das gästen theater ist sofort
anders spielt auch eine rolle übrigens
ganz intuitiv also ich habe das bei
einem früheren schweizer freund mal
erlebt der normalerweise sich wie ein
schweizer verhielt aber er spricht
hervorragend arabisch kaum rückte er in
ägypten oder so ein schreck geht das ist
gebeten und gefuchtel und gemachte los
ja also das heißt die die die sprache
bringen auch so etwas hervor ein
bisschen ein anderes gästen theater ich
glaube daran dass menschen die ihr leben
schreiben verbringen beide seien sehr
verzweiflungs reiche beruf und eine
berufung ist oftmals die tun das nicht
ohne gewissen bruch und einer gewissen
distanz ohne etwas was sie vielleicht
bewältigen oder verarbeiten müssen
würden sie sagen dass das biografisch
auf sie auch zutrifft ja das schon also
die bewältigung von schwerstem
verstörenden leid das ist schon eine
gute quelle für literatur jetzt ganz
gleichgültig ob es ein schicksal einer
ganzen familie ist dass man fliegen muss
oder ob es ein privates schicksal ist
ein unglück krank hatte liebe des
selbstmordes das was weiß ich es gibt ja
alles in zu hause oder der verquere
eltern hat die eineiigen das sind alles
tolle voraussetzungen
trotzdem haben ja viele menschen so ein
schicksal und können nicht darüber
schreiben
das heißt darüber schreiben zu dürfen
und damit aber auch noch geld zu den
verdienen mit seinem leid das finde ich
eine ganz große das ist ein sechser im
lotto
derweil leiht haben viele menschen also
ein echtes existenz privileg absolut
klar und sie werden ist ja auch dadurch
nicht zumindest ich schreibe ja nicht
konkret darüber
ich schreibe eigentlich boden das
unbewusste schreibt mit aber das
unbewusste ist heftig beim schreiben
beschreibt irgendwie sein eigene text
herunter liegend ohne dass man es
erkennt man aber ich bin sicher das hat
alles eine große entlastung form ja eine
glückliche entlastungs forum die einem
dafür könnte es dieses sprudelnde und
diese sehr frei dynamik des unbewussten
die spürt man auch in ihren texten dass
die über worden sind und die sprache
selbst feiern aber sie sagten ja es gibt
so ein traumatisches ereignis in ihrer
jugend und die sprechen ja eigentlich
auch sehr offen darüber bei manchen
anlässen
das besteht darin dass ihr vater als er
elf jahre waren sich umbrachte und
können sie sagen was das in ihnen damals
bewirkt hat also es war massiv also ich
liebte ihn sehr
er war aber vorher schon sehr immer
wieder verstörend also er hat die
familie auch wirklich also nicht war
überhaupt nicht aggressiv
er war zurückgezogen hat sich hat
praktisch immer mal zwei drei monate in
radikaler finsternis verbracht wo er für
uns auch nicht zugänglich war meine
mutter natürlich in heller aufregung
auch sie können sich vorstellen bei
einem arzt ist es schwierig da muss ja
irgendwie da sein für seine patienten
die mutter es war eine zeit in der
psychische verstörungen als schwerer
marke galten gar für einen arzt meine
mutter es ist vertuschen gleichen
stellvertreter für die praxis finden
also ende haftet er unglaublich viel und
für uns kinder war das alles furchtbar
kann ich nur sagen
trotzdem ich liebte ihn sehr und er war
auch zumindest in meiner frühen zeit ein
sehr guter vater gewesen
das heißt also ein aufgeweckter kerler
kann man sagen der der großzügig war der
der wenn es ihm gut ging wirklich ein
mensch ein mensch der leute immer
eingeladen hat der auf dem kind witzig
war weil er hat ja ja die geistige
interessen waren konnte die schön
erzählen und also ich lebte in serie
wenn ich jetzt raus höre zwar einen
fragt einer depression einer schweren
depression
es ist ja so trotzdem kommt man nicht
ganz davon weg diese menschen zu
beschuldigen warum hast du mich
verlassen warum hast du nicht an uns
gedacht ich stelle mir vor gerade in der
jugend ist es schwer vollends zu
begreifen dass es ein akt der krankheit
war und nicht indem man auch moralisch
beliebt ich belege es bis heute
moralisch das ist nicht nur ein problem
der jugend weil ich finde schon dass man
depression her oder hin
das kann ich nicht so leicht
entschuldigen wenn man eine familie hat
und für andere verantwortlich ist schon
ein bisschen überlegen muss was man da
tut
zumal eines weiß ich wirklich nicht
vergessen kann und was ich richtig als
übel ansehen muss ist die tatsache dass
er sich in seiner praxis erhängt hat und
seine frau den anblick zugemutet hat das
finde ich massiv also ein arzt hat gift
schränke auf und das ein bisschen damit
zumindest besser aussieht
also das heißt das ist schon eine
radikale aggression das eine sehr
radikale aggression und das konnte ich
nie so ganz entschuldigen
ich war wenn sie die einzige in der
familie darauf auch wehrhaft reagiert
hat und dadurch besser weggekommen ist
weil sie diese aggression noch
zugelassen aber ist sie zugelassen habe
und dadurch mich selber aggressionen in
manchen zusammenhängen ist kräftigend
für die persönlichkeit ja
ja nicht so etwas schlucken ja also die
meine mutter und mein älterer bruder
irgendein bruder hat das geschluckt in
gewisser weise ja wir haben beide sehr
anders reagiert aber ich glaube ich bin
davon gekommen weil meine aggressionen
irgendwie form und annehmen durfte und
musste den zorn denn sieht man wenn die
sich lande aber es geht natürlich auch
ein begriff der schuld wenn man liest
dann sagen sie sind eigentlich sehr
religiös geprägt aufgewachsen von ihrer
großmutter und die ultimative schuld in
einem religiösen auch christlichen
weltbild ist ja eigentlich der
selbstmord das ist ja das ist er sehr
wohl nur es gibt natürlich formen das
aber nicht formen des selbst sondern es
gibt situationen in den selbstmord
entsteht die absolut vereinbar sind
also wenn sie denken also jüdische
familie die fahrer die fordert
reputation steht und weiß was passiert
und ist jemand aus dem fenster wirft
oder gift schluckt ist ein anderer
umstände sind vollkommen andere umstände
im übrigen hat auch kurioser weise mein
liebling dann zwei selbstmörder in der
comedia gespielt wenn man so will und
unerklärlicher weise einen selbstmörder
nämlich parade lavinia der sport in der
hölle
er hat sich auf gegner der ist durch den
großen friedrich wenn sizilianischen in
den knast gesteckt worden und der hat
ein übles schicksal ja dass in einem
blutenden zweig verband und dann gibt es
aber einen anderen einen antiken thorium
die die die auch ein selbstmörder der
aber die sed die ankommenden seelen
geleiten darauf ja da sehen sie eine
differenzierung die auch schon im
mittelalterlichen welt vorgenommen
werden wo würden sie denn dann sagen ihr
vater würden sie das sagen da gibt es
entscheidende umstände oder sind sie
dazu nicht in der lage
wo würden sie denn da platzieren ja ich
hab ich aber psychologisch gesprochen
als ich dann später seine mutter
kennenlernte die uns dann besucht hat
die auch meines achtens relativ verrückt
war so er hat dass er hat nie darüber so
gesprochen als er hat uns da kein
realistisches bild vermitteln und
außerdem er konnte ja gar nicht mehr
zurück das heißt er hat die über
jahrzehnte nicht gesehen muss man auch
mal sagen ja
wir haben sie auch nicht gesehen aber
die fand ich als kind als sie dann kam
da war ich so sieben oder acht
die fand ich ganz schrecklich im
gegensatz zu meiner deutschen großmutter
die wunderbar war und die waren sehr
sehr schwierig also die war es das war
so eine ganz kleine zartem zu riesigen
augen irgendwie so aber unglaublich
anspruchsvoll also die hat die ganze
familie sofort terrorisiert und ich habe
zu einem als kind zu einem großen
befreiungsschlag angehoben indem ich sie
mitsamt dax sind wir im wald spaziert
die kannte sich nicht los dann habe ich
einen dackel in atmen und bin
zurückgerannt weil ich dachte so werden
wir sie endlich los das hat ja fast
schon etwas mehr verstand gelacht weil
es ging ihnen ähnlich auch mal war
kürzlich ein sehr bemerkenswerten satz
gesagt finde ich der ging um religion
und das drohpotenzial der religion und
sie sagten die religion braucht schon
etwas wie ein drohpotenzial auch auf das
jenseits hin und wenn sie das verliert
verliert sie fast alles oder das
wesentliche ja wobei man natürlich das
drohpotenzial kann man natürlich so oder
so sehen es gibt formen des
drohpotenzial als die statistisch
manipulierbar sind die sind schrecklich
das gab es wenn sie an die verbrennungen
und der ketzer und der frauen unter
juden denken das ist ja alles scheußlich
also christliche religion ist wahrlich
beschaffen haftet über jahrhunderte
hinweg mit grauenhaften exzessen des
bösen und der ja also das kann nicht nur
irgend da ist ja diese droge auch da ja
das heißt also da kann man dann nur ein
gerechter weise überhaupt nicht dafür
seien aber wenn man sozusagen ganz ohne
ein kleines schwert das über allem hängt
lebt also in gar keiner weise mehr die
sorge haben muss wenn man auch die
wüstesten geschichten anstellt wenn man
sich wie hitler gebärdet wie stahl leben
wie kim il sung und wie sie alle heißen
gebärdet und dann fröhlich in den himmel
marschieren darf dann frage ich mich
wozu überhaupt religion ja sie hat dann
überhaupt ihr ihre die religion hat dann
was sie tun muss ist eine sättigende
wirkung entfalten und das kann man nicht
nur durch lange reden
verstehen sie also die die menschliche
entschuldigung ein
die die menschliche natur muss auch
beeindruckt werden aber da gibt es ja so
ist ein fast kipp bild einerseits gibt
es in der region das große vergebung
versprechen das tatsächlich alles
vergeben werden kann und andererseits
die option zu sagen es ist nicht alles
möglich es wird konsequenzen haben
und da würden sie sagen ist die kippe zu
sehr auf der vergebung auf der tröstung
auf dem allheilmittel des gewissens
beruhigende verfahren mittlerweile ja
bei den beiden kirchen bei den beiden
kirchen christlichen kirchen auf jeden
fall also bei den evangelisch in der
evangelischen kirche noch etwas stärker
direkt da gar nicht mehr davon also da
gibt es im grunde das sünden bohren das
hat er völlig aufgehört also sind alle
in ordnung wie hier irgendwie rum
sperren sind alle sind wir ganz lieb und
mal quatsch aber trotzdem würde ich
sagen na ja eine gewisse auflockerung
hut sein müssen ja also sag mal von dem
drohpotenzial die ist das früher auf
aufgefahren wurde musste man wegkommen
gott sei dank das ist auch eine erlösung
nur ist immer die frage des maßes es ist
ja und heim an biss verloren hat man
denn bis verloren und die diese religion
die jüdische und christliche religion
die haben natürlich auch dass auch der
islam in gewisser weise natürlich auch
haben natürlich schon die aufgabe auch
informiert die menschen zu einem
besseren verhalten zu erziehen und nur
in freiheit und mit schönen
liebenswürdig im nachtreten ist es damit
nicht getan es gibt ja nun eine
verkörperung dieses potenzials die
kulturell extrem mächtig ist das ist die
hölle ein werk das in der hölle spielt
und mit der das spiel des tanzes
göttliche komödie wir können uns mal ein
bild ansehen
hier sehen wir eine illustration von
gustave doré wo dante mit seinem
dichterkollegen vergil durch die hölle
wartet und diese leiden betrachtet
können sie sich vorstellen weil ich kann
es eigentlich nicht dass wir den
menschen des mittelalters das nicht nur
eine geschichte war sondern ein realer
erwartung eine echte existenz option ja
aber zur hat ja ja sicher also ich
glaube zwar dass der mittelalterliche
mensch jetzt nicht immer nur furios
religiös war das glaube ich überhaupt
nicht also die haben es ist auch immer
wieder vergessen also mensch kann nicht
ständig religiöser sie seien als kate
und mit sich dem also leute die
schaffung müssen die bauern die sich
plagen müssen die was weiß ich die
handel treiben die haben doch nicht alle
fünf minuten gut gedacht nie im leben er
hat das heißt also die waren auch schon
immer wieder frei ging ja und haben halt
macht was ihr so wollten nur das
drohpotenzial war aufrecht erhalten und
wurde ritualisiert immer wieder
veranstaltet das heißt also die sind in
die kirche gegangen das waren sie ja
wirklich alles drin und da haben sie
noch mal mächtig rituelle germania wurde
hammer rausgeholt ja dass das war doch
der fall
und wenn sie mal so alte predigen von
abraham a santa clara reden doch nur
gottes wille wert ist möchte man
vielleicht lieber haben ja aber in ihrem
neuen buch das pfingst unterkommen
eigene eigentlich sehr viel strenger
zusammen es geht einmal um dante um
einen dante kongress es geht um die
schuld und die frage des jenseits und es
geht um die perspektive der erlösung ich
mag vielleicht kurz die handlung sagen
es ist ein kongress von dante forschern
über die göttliche komödie und im
verlauf dieses kongresses geschieht ein
wunder und 33 dieser dante forscher
wiegen gen himmel endlich denn darauf
indem sie eine göttliche sprache
sprechen und eine einziger der held
ihres romans bleibt zurück und ist mit
der aufgabe belastet das wunder erst mal
zu verstehen und zweiten sich auch zu
fragen warum wurde ich eigentlich nicht
mitgenommen das genaue grund zuzugs
romans
was würden sie sagen wenn wir vom namen
sprechen dieser held heißt ja gottfried
was das was zweifelt er warum wurde er
nicht mitgenommen hat zwar einen namen
sogar der nachname hat noch den
religiösen beiklang also ein großer auch
religiös inspirierte mal ein ganz großer
maler
also ehrlich doppelt konvertiert als
eigentlich ein geschöpf das sozusagen
wie aus gottes hand gesprungen scheint
vom namen her aber gut der mann ist und
damals professor minister frankfurter
universität und der hat versteht
versteht zwar ein bisschen etwas von
religion das muss als dante vorschau
auch tun aber der ist sagen wir so wenig
religiös zu hause in seinem denken
sonstigen denken in seinem handgelenk
wie die allermeisten menschen heute in
uns erinnern
während sie dann eine person von der sie
selbst sagen würden ich glaube noch ein
wunder ist könnte an wunder glauben im
naiv im sinne leider nicht also ich bin
nichts in alles in allem was man mein
normales leben betrifft bin ich
überhaupt nicht wunder gläubig und bin
auch sogar skeptisch wenn wir leute dann
also so fabelhafte dinge erzählen wobei
es in der realität doch manchmal dinge
gibt die zumindest die kein wunder in
einem in einem übernatürlichen sinn sind
aber die menschen wirklich als wunder
ansehen müssen wenn sie daran denken es
gab mal bist du hattest ist zwei mal
zwei mal vom himmel gefallen durch den
flugzeugabsturz hat beides mal überleben
also die frage kann ihre lebenserfahrung
die total ganz schrecklich war und dann
aber in richtung mündete also die kann
von sich selber nur als ein wunder
phänomen sprechen was uns der das
verstauen
statistisch uns nie vorher so da ist das
wunder aber sehr profan das hat er nun
das ist trotzdem halte zwar als wurden
also aber es gibt natürlich trotzdem
immer wieder
also die dient ist ich würde sagen so
ein wunder schleicht u/min menschen ja
das ist nun ist es kein habhaft das
wunder aber denken sie daran es gibt
doch immer wieder menschen die relativ
glaubwürdig zb vorahnungen haben dass
ein naher verwandter sterben wird
das ist man mag es als in vielen zweifel
in vielen fällen wird man es an zweifeln
müssen ich glaube nicht dass es nicht
auch sein kann
ich habe die gabe sie gericht aber da
können wir ja nicht interessieren es
gibt zwei arten von wundern sagen wir
dass eine wunder besteht darin dass
naturgesetze aufgehoben werden also wenn
wir beide jetzt anfangen zu schweben und
gen himmel gehen
das andere ist ein wunder dass sich
darauf bezieht dass aus einer anderen
aus einer transzendenz oder jenseits
fähre kontakt mit uns aufgenommen wird
ja das ist eigentlich eine form von
informationsübertragung das zweite
würden sie sagen das ist vielleicht
sogar etwas was gar nicht so leicht zu
bestreiten ist ja ich würde es für mich
nicht bestreiten also aber dazu ist
natürlich ein gewisser aktivität maler
selbst nötig das heißt ohne die
religiöse erziehung die ich nun mal als
kind hatte und die ich positiv bewertet
habe da ich habe es geliebt als kind die
großmutter war meine lieblingsfigur und
er hat von religiösen dingen hydro und
erzählt hat also nicht irgendwie ihre
zeigefinger ausgefahren sondern die hat
irgendeiner und unglaublich lebens
würdigen weise mit einer schönen stimme
davon erzählt und das ist für ein kind
toll
das heißt also ich kann einfach es ist
durch einen menschen ganz einfach
vermittelt und deswegen hat sich das in
mich gesetzt und ist mir auch durch alle
schwankungen oder pubertät durch was ich
spartacus bolschewiki leninisten was
alles gab irgendwie durch bildung sie
haben sozusagen späten 70er jahre ist es
geblieben
aber was ist den man könnte sich jetzt
fragen ich bin christin ich glaube an
gott was würden sie denn sagen woran
glauben sie denn nicht glauben dass
sondern glauben an was ist der kern
dieses glaubens den sie pflegen ich
glaube ich schon wieder gehalten ist ich
denke es ist eher eine art hoffnung dass
es doch bitte gott geben möge so würde
ich das ausdrücken also ich bin mir
nicht sicher
und ich weiß nur dass es gibt zwei
grundlegende momente die wiederkehren in
meinem leben in tiefer verzweiflung
fange ich sofort an im nach nachts zu
hause zu beten
ja das ist wie das das kann ich gar
nicht abstellen das ist sofort da also
und zwar jetzt nicht in einem in einem
betenden regel kreislauf sondern wie ein
kind 44 jährige die sich etwas ab bietet
von
der mächtige ist und das zweite ist es
ist die freundliche form also zum
beispiel ich trete hinaus irgendwie
unter einen baum auf dem 100 spatzen
hocken und wir schaffen die auf ihre
weise und bin so was von glücklich dass
ich in der welt sein darf und dieses
muntere und diesen diesen himmel darüber
sehen darf dass ich versucht mittag kurz
der hähnchen und zweiter grund das ist
schon klasse dieses leben willst du mir
geschenkt hast das ist bank das ist naiv
ich weiß aber das ist ja so mystisches
staunen dass es überhaupt etwas gibt und
nicht vielmehr nichts
ja ich weiß ja auch etwas so schönes
gibt der winterwelt und ich darin frei
herum herum schwadronieren darauf
irgendwo irgendwie folgen
das ist auf der einen seite diese diese
erlösung die von oben kommt das etwas
ein wunder gereicht wird das ist ein
veritabler aber etwas schönes gereicht
wird und auf der anderen seite die
menschliche verzweiflung die ja auch
immer wieder kehrt also mit erlöse mich
von diesem und jenem leiten dann ist
klar diese beseeltheit auch die
schönheit der schöpfung einfach dankbar
anzunehmen
die müsste doch und reicht vielen
gläubigen menschen auch wenn sie sagen
und trotzdem zweifle ich zweifle ich
macht sie das leiden der welt zweifelt
das leiden der welt macht mich in so
verzweifeln weil man natürlich den furor
gegen gott da richten kann also zb einer
meiner absoluten kronzeugen in dieser
angelegenheit es ist das stärkste
gedichtes überhaupt kennen das ist jetzt
so nelson der in auschwitz war und an
langgedicht schrieb auf jedes das ist
absolut irre von hamm biermann
entsetzlich übersetzt das kann nur
nebenbei bemerkt aber ein sehr
tiefgläubiger mensch stärker als hiob in
der bibel das ist wirklich starker als
hier hier bis ist salatblätter welches
neben das ist das kriegt man das ist
wirklich schafft eine mit erhobener
faust eine solche gottes anklage nach
oben schleuder das kenne ich sonst nicht
das ist das schaffst gedicht von einem
tief gläubigen menschen das kann ein
atheist überhaupt nicht machen
ja das hat mich muss ich muss sagen das
hat mich umgehauen ich habe zufällig
mein radio an
für sendungen gemacht da wurde das auf
jedes rezitiert und ich hatte über haben
sie wollte ausgehen mit ein paar leute
ins restaurant irgendwie so finster ich
wäre wirklich ich war wie gebannt weil
das also von einer unglaublichen wucht
diese dieses gedicht das heißt man kann
das interesse nicht interessieren
menschen die damit kämpfen ja die die
das nicht irgendwie so abtun als fahrer
gibt es nicht und ist auf wunsch nach
dem tod und so weiter weil ich das nicht
glaube kein mensch kann sich vorstellen
dass es ihn nach dem tode nicht mehr
gibt das nichts ist nicht denkbar es
wird sofort wir haben wir sind darauf
angewiesen alles mit vorstellungen zu
füllen auf der stelle
wir können das nicht nicht denken aber
da würde man doch sagen wir haben gerade
nach auschwitz auch in der literatur
stimmen gehört die sehr wohl dass nichts
nicht nur denken sondern auch
formulieren können man könnte sagen beck
hätte es eine gestalt die ganz
sympathisch sagt wir müssen nicht das
wir können das nicht nur nicht wir
müssen das sogar tun
kurioserweise beckett ist meint
gewährsmann in dieser stunde dann
wirklich gleich sagen da habe ich bin
ich eine andere beckett iranerin ja
warum aber wenn wenn er so dachte was er
tat da haben sie schon recht aber warum
ist es alles immer gespickt mit
bibelzitaten und warum ist das gespickt
mit dantes hölle und bürger thorium aber
die bibelzitate sie können wenn sie da
ein detektivisches vermögen haben
praktisch bei jedem sechsten beckett
satz denken sie auch das klingt aber
zumindest wenn sie eben die
amerikanische bibel kennen auch das
klingt aber schwer nach usw
das ist immer noch ein abarbeiten immer
noch einmal aufnehmen mit dieser
tradition kann also sowohl kafka als
auch beckett sind die großen garanten
dass in der großen literatur des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts die nicht mehr
in v-form gläubig waren das gar nicht
mehr sagen konnten verständlicherweise
nach allem was passiert ist oder karte
noch nicht erlebt aber trotzdem aber
trotzdem ich würde sagen das ist die
hochmögende und zugleich auch
verzweifelte gottsucher bande ist da am
werk und das natürlich auch die dynamik
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe die die
geistige bewegung die literatur selbst
in dieser spannung hält
immer diese transzendenz immer das
jenseits mit zu bedenken weil dadurch
die größten geistigen leistung überhaupt
entstehen können verstehe ich sie da
richtig ja also ich gut ist es ist
ungerecht zu sagen dass also jede gute
literatur so sei das finde ich jetzt
auch übertrieben es gibt durchaus
literatur die sich sehr viel stärker dem
reinen realismus verpflichtet und die
trotzdem funktioniert und gut sein kann
also ganz so ganz so scharf für dich da
jetzt nicht über über die anderen her
die anderen herfallen meiner kollegen ja
das wäre ja eine das wäre auch ungerecht
aber trotzdem ist sagen wir mal sind
viele autoren die zumindest nicht
entzücken
die haben zumindest auf verquere weise
teilweise natürlich auch erschütterte
weise nicht nicht diese ja nicht alle
nicht gutgläubig und kurz also nicht
nicht auf naive weise sind sie gar nicht
ja aber sie haben das immer im gepäck
und sie sind auch letztlich verzweifelt
darüber dass dieses gepäck irgendwie
immer so durcheinander fliegt ja dass er
katar keine ruhe im karton ist auf die
sind ja eben auf eine interessante art
nicht
nicht weil ich verzweifelt aber sie sind
auch verzweifelt das bringt uns ja
eigentlich zu einer zweiten kern gestalt
eines jüngeren romans von ihm hans
blumenberg einer der größten und
wichtigsten philosophen der gar nicht
allgemein bekanntes ihr könnt ihr sagen
das werk von hans blumenberg ist auch
eine auseinandersetzung genau mit dieser
spannung und es thematisiert die
unmöglichkeit sich von diesen religiösen
motiven und fragen jemals lösen zu
können
ja das ist auch der grund warum ich doch
immer so gefesselt hat von jugend an
eigentlich hat mit 19 sein ist das buch
gelesen nicht verstanden aber ich fand's
toll also und bei ihm ist genauso wie
sie sagen also auf der einen seite keine
religiöse festigkeit mehr keine
gewissheit ist es alles weggeflogen auch
als
mit jüdischen vorfahren das ganze
schicksal teile der familie haben das
mit erlitten er selber war auch in
gefahr dass da ist die welt total
durcheinander geraten
aber hans blumenberg hat halt in seinen
schriften das ist praktisch in jedem
text drin ist es durch wittert von
bezügen aus der theologie aus dem
gottesverständnis heraus das ist ein
das ist eine interessante
verschwisterung mit der philosophie ohne
dass man ihnen als an den gläubigen
menschen darstellen kann
einer der interessantesten gedanken und
das führt auf viele motive die auch in
ihrer literatur präsent sind von
bloomberg ist der dass es eine spannung
zwischen der lebenszeit und der weltzeit
gibt ich weiß dass mein leben 80 jahre
währen wird ich weiß dass dieses
universum milliarden jahre existiert hat
und existieren wird und blumenberg sagt
diese spannung ist für den menschen
eigentlich kaum auszuhalten und kaum zu
bewältigen und der trost der muss in der
sprache der reflexion dieses
missverhältnisses liegen ja das hat mich
genau genau diese these also mit aber
auch sprachhilfe wiederum ja also als
rettungsmanöver er weil das denken dass
sprache die sprache selber ja immer auch
das denken immer informiert hat und das
ist eigentlich das gleiche phänomen wie
wenn man das nichts ist nicht
vorstellbar wird aber durch sprachliche
wölbungen und brückenschläge ständig
sozusagen wiederum aufgebaut in einem in
einem etwas hartes wesen ja das
interessante dann und genau diese
phänomene haben in tief berührt deswegen
ist es auch mein haus philosoph geworden
weil weil ich dass ich es kein wunder
dass mich also kafka beckett und blumen
hans blumenberg dass die mich so
interessiert haben aber das heißt ja
auch dass die sprache der verzweifelte
versuche etwas zu formulieren was sich
der formulierung dann letztlich doch
entziehen muss ja natürlich also dass
das unsagbare letztlich so dass das
radikale nicht wissen über bestimmte
phänomene die wir uns teilweise erhoffen
oder die wir fürchten oder die wir zum
vergnügen bearbeiten das ist ja immer
nicht nur vor stunden und schönheit
sowieso beides ist es ja auch
kasperletheater habe keine aktuelles
kasperletheater daraus gemacht also ist
ja klar der hat die burschen hat es auch
spaß gemacht so vollkommen klar ja also
es ist alles drin und aber also mir ist
immer wahnsinnig langweilig mit diesen
in der regel zumindest mit diesen
hausbackenen realisten ja die glauben
das leben so wie sie es führen und so
und dann ist es halt zu ende und da wird
man halt nur verbrennen drin geht es
irgendwie so weiter also das ist mir
unangenehm kann ihnen sagen was passiert
wenn sie noch einmal am tag etwas extrem
wesentliches nämlich ein wesen das nicht
sprechen kann ein löwe er taucht auf
einmal in seinem leben auf er schreibt
uns in ihrem roman ist das so es hat
einmal ein löwe im arbeitszimmer liegt
und dieser löwe schweigt die ganze zeit
wie es in ihrem werk insgesamt so ist
dass die tiere eine ganz eigentümliche
funktion haben
sie sind tröster und schweiger sie
schweigen sie trösten und sie verstehen
sehr viel
der löwe versteht ja weiß es nicht aber
eigentlich denke er steht für ja oder
gedanken über tragend versteht es
erfüllt und es gab zwei dinge die mich
jetzt zum löwen geführt haben bei
blumenberg blumenberg hat sehr schön
über löwen geschrieben das hat ihnen
also das heißt ich habe gleich mal schon
welche futter euro von seiner seite her
gehabt diesen blöden dahin zu platzieren
und zum anderen wollte ich ja überhaupt
keinen realistischen roman schreiben der
womöglich blumenbergs biografie und sind
biografische sprengsel drinnen aber ist
keine biografie und am besten kommt man
von so etwas los wenn man etwas erfindet
das nicht sein kann aber das sozusagen
ein fixpunkt im roman wird um dem dann
alles kreist ja da muss ja immer darum
gedacht werden
die dürfen aber nie den fehler machen
und kafka hat eben gott sei dank auch
nie gemacht dass sie dann noch andere
wunderliche fixpunkte finden dann landen
sie in so einer schwebt form dass das
über natürlich in die kanne keine kraft
mehr hat das heißt ein löwe genügt ja
die einlösen aber nicht mehr wir
brauchen eine sprechende rate
ungebrochener kann singenden vogel der
uns irgendwie eine bachkantate
vorwiegend ja also aber noch mal
nachgefragt weil das ja sehr spannend
ist auch für blumenberg in der
biografischen existenz ein mann der sich
unverstanden fühlte der unglaublich
alleine war hatte am ende seines lebens
gar niemanden hatte wie er selbst sagt
dem schreiben oder mit dem entsprechen
könnte und das tier das ihn tröstet und
vor allem von dem er sich am meisten
verstanden fühlt ist ein sprachloses
wesen man könnte ja fast denken sprache
tut gar nicht das was sie soll sie ist
gar nicht gut für unser verstehen
komische figur auch muss man sagen ja
war nachtarbeiter hat nächte
durchgearbeitet spannend standard später
auf so jemand fehlt ja aus dem
gesellschafts rahmen ja dann kann man ja
nicht abend sagen wir mal um 8 uhr
gemütlich zum abendessen oder
mittagessen einladen da ist ja nicht
verfügbar das heißt also dass es
funktioniert ja alles nicht mehr das
gesetz die um geselligkeit hat er
gewählt hat warum sie gewählt hat ist
eine andere frage aber aber er hat sie
hat sie den weg eingeschlagen und dann
ist natürlich so etwas wie einen solchen
herrn einen löwen der schweigt hinzu
zugesehen eigentlich schon das richtige
weil er hat zwar noch telefonisch mit
drei personen mit drei herren immer
nachts kontakt gehabt er hatte immer
angerufen mitten in der nacht also aus
um zwei sehr spät leute die schwer
schaffen mussten alle drei redakteure
von oder auch und verleger dabei also
wichtige leute mit denen er dann spät
nachts manchmal konferiert hat aber da
gibt es die komischsten erzählungen man
sagt ja so diese stunden zwischen drei
und vier und nach erst merkt man auch in
der religion oft das sind die stunden
der wahrheit in denen das bewusstsein
ein ganz spezielles ein spezielles
stimmung an dem schreiben sie auch
nachts ist das für sie auch die
produktive und stunden schreiben nicht
aber die einfälle kommen mir nach zürich
schreibt sie manchmal auf also aber nur
den skizzierten sprich stichwörter also
das stimmt also ich habe eigentlich fast
alle ideen immer so kurz vorm
einschlafen oder wenn ich nachts
aufwache und wieder ein bisschen macht
bin ich habe am tag kann ich
relativ stetig arbeiten da habe ich
keine probleme damit dass dann habt ihr
nix kann man verbessern da bin ich
relativ leicht tat 6 aber ich kann
eigentlich am tag keine richtig guten
ideen haben die kommt macht das sehr
interessant weil das heißt ja auch der
einfall das heißt ideen sind eigentlich
dinge die zu uns kommen und die wir gar
nicht erzeugen können wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe ja also zum beispiel
wenn es gerade noch im roman ist
geschrieben ich weiß zwar was jetzt
gerade machen muss aber okay aber ich
werde jetzt erstmal keinen neuen roman
schreiben nur so langsam irgendwie im
nächsten halben jahr wird mich werden
ideen kommen viele kommen und gehen und
sind weg und man weiß das wird nix
irgendwie sehr schnell aber irgendeine
wird sich durchsetzen
gegen alle ist massiv die ergreift und
plötzlich die npd nimmt dann besetzt
besitz von allem und bei mir ist es
grundsätzlich nicht einfach nur die
stories ein bisschen die story auch aber
er sieht man hauptfigur also die dann
immer präsenter wird also wo sich
gedanklich was anlage hat irgendwie so
und dann kann man kann aber auch so
langsam mal loslegen das kann man so
fast sagen die das ist der löwe der auf
einmal auf ihrem täglich sitzt und nicht
mehr weggeht
also dann blumenberg war nur mit dem
löwen machbar also über blumberg habe
ich mir schon viel nachgedacht aber ich
wollte eigentlich keinen roman schreiben
kam gar nicht auf die idee zunächst aber
in dem moment wo ich den löwen hat ja
dass ich für diesen philosophen der muss
dahin ja dann funktioniert ein teil in
ihrer literatur die auch in diesen
beiden büchern ist immer dass literatur
auch immer über literatur schreibt und
sich im dialog mit alten werken befinden
muss gerade in ihrem ganze buch das
pfingstwunder geht es ja auch um das
konto und um die frage dass literatur
eigentlich erst seit jüngerer zeit
gelesen wird und früher gesprochen und
sogar gesungen wurde ist das immer noch
etwas was sie für nötig dass dieser
zugang zur gesungen und gesprochen
literatur ja heute gar nicht mehr für
uns aktuell ist das ist schade weil ich
vermisse das jetzt nicht in der prosa
weil da ist das muss man jetzt nicht
immer voller ist gelesen bekommen und es
kann man wirklich selber lesen aber
jetzt haben wir eine eine schöne
dichtung vorgetragen zu bekommen ist
schon etwas sehr anderes
oder gar vertont in einem sehr schönen
lieder wieder zu finden das sind schon
ganz besondere ereignisse
also dass das liebe ich doch sehr wenn
es gelingt es ist ja gerade etwas
passiert in der literatur denn jemand
hat einen literaturpreis bekommen zum
zweiten mal eigentlich das jahr davor
war es auch schon keine literaten
eigenen sinne der einen sänger war der
songtexte geschrieben hat bob dylan
würden sie denn sagen dass diese texte
literatur sind sind das cantos unserer
zeit als sie sind sehr gut
ja also definition definieren kann ich
das phänomen so vielleicht nicht aber
aber es ist sehr sehr gut keine frage
aber ich hab' ich habe drei ich kann
drei vier oder fünf musikalische
leuchten in meinem leben die alles alles
andere versäuft praktisch davor das ist
pergolesi das ist monte verde das ist
bach und das top-talent dazwischen ist
nichts also auch so dass ich immer gerne
konzerten geben dass auch höhere aber
ich vergesse es auf der stelle es
bedeutet mir nichts
das heißt also mit vieren komme ich
völlig aus und bob dylan ist einer davon
insofern große war ich sehr beeindruckt
auch ab 12 entdeckt und und auch durch
meine hatte dazwischen ein bisschen
schreckliche phasen gehabt irgendwie
doch die treue gehalten immer die
hoffnung es wird wieder besser und das
alterswerk ist toll
sie haben man als den schnellsten mann
auf erden bezeichnet
ich finde ihn attraktiv also nicht schön
im sinne von als es gab sehr viel
schönere schauspieler ist keine frage
aber ich finde ihn in dieser leicht mir
gefällt dieses schnur geht es ist
leichter ja dieses so ein bisschen außer
sow bis sind ja die wagen seien bislang
runterstellen irgendwie so diese dieses
leicht verdreht skeptisch auch das
gefühl ich schon sehr sehr klasse also
also dieses figurale auch darin das
finde ich toll
glauben sie dass die vergabe an bob
dylan auch etwas mit den jetzigen
entwicklungen in amerika zu tun hat dass
man ihn gleichsam als ein symbol für ein
amerika sieht dass gerade im untergang
begriffen ist ja das mag sein ich finde
es trotzdem falsch also ich war nicht so
begeistert über diese nobelpreisvergabe
weil er jetzt muss man wirklich ein
bisschen anders noch denken also dass da
ist jetzt auch immer stärker in vielen
in vielen domain und das
des ästhetischen ist permanent etwas am
werk das man sich also sozusagen dass
man etwas wählen will was irgendwie
aufsehen erregt er weiß also jetzt so
keiner dran gedacht hat und etwas ganz
anderes kommt das ist die von dem keller
wusste man das so nicht kommen wird
diese großen leute des showgeschäfts er
gehört zum showgeschäft haben riesige
preis er immer schon kassiert also ich
finde dass und es gibt verdammt gute
amerikanische autoren die an denen das
immerzu vorbeiging amerika nordamerika
ist so groß wie ganz europa verdammt
noch mal dass es da mindestens 20 dollar
schriftsteller gibt von denen einsamer
sechs oder sieben des längst verdient
hätte ist es aber ganz einfach deswegen
ärgert mich das schon so sehr ich bob
dylan liebe und dem herrn alles gründe
das hat damit nichts zu tun aber ich
finde das falsch die entscheidung ich
bin noch auf ein anderes thema zu
sprechen kommen dass für sie biografisch
glaube ich auch sehr wichtig war es geht
um eine rede die sie im märz 2014
gehalten hatten und in dieser rede ist
eine kritik der machbarkeit der modernen
medizin sprechen sie dort aus
insbesondere was die geburt und den tod
angeht sie sagen wir sind jetzt in einer
lage die beiden existenz tore geburt und
tod so weit zu manipulieren dass es für
uns schädlich ist wir erheben uns zu
göttern das klingt ja zunächst einmal
nach eltern etwas frömmelnden
kulturpessimismus dadurch aber nicht
unbedingt die religion dazu also das ist
jetzt glaube ich nicht zu sehr
meine sorge wenn man so will die dann
teilweise in 45 zu aggressiven setzen
kulminiert ist also was was auch
wirklich dumm war aber die grund sorge
die dahinter steht die halte ich nicht
verdummen
das heißt mir geht es darum dass in wenn
wir in einer immer weiteren maße
versuchen unser schicksal zu bestimmen
das ist ein weg der unfreiheit das heißt
in dem falle der bestimmung unserer
schicksale sind wie immer schuldiger
wenn etwas nicht gelingt das ist ja das
furchtbar dann wenn sie machen wir
nochmal ein beispiel von was mich
besonders daran
immer was sie furchtbar fand wenn sie
wenn kinder entstehen bis schon das noch
mit machbarkeits kriterien eines
kataloges also sie wünschen sich einen
blondierten gründen schönen reken als
samenspender mit paul klee und mittlere
nobelpreisträger das ist ja so aber es
gibt ja diese dinge diese vorstellung
nachher ist halt doch rasch war gefahren
hab halt pech gehabt
dann kommt aber etwas auf ich möchte
nicht die mutter von so jemandem sein
das heißt das hoffnungs potenzial was
aus so einem kind werden muss ist riesig
das heißt früher sind halt kinder auf
die welt kommen und ob jetzt aus uns was
wird oder nicht ist nicht gott sei dank
nie alleine in der verantwortung der
eltern gelegen
das heißt ich habe angst vor der
verantwortung die sich diese menschen
eigentlich aufladen das wissen sie gar
nicht ja weil das kind keine gabe mehr
ist sondern gleichsam ein produkt ist
ein produkt und von einem produkt aber
verlangen dass es funktioniert ja ich
möchte wenn ich ihnen entscheiden
fernseher kaufen möchte ich bitte wenn
ich das geld hinlegen und die müssen ja
auch ziemlich viel geld beraten aber ich
glaube dass das funktioniert und das tut
aber menschen egal wie sie auf die welt
kommen sind schwierig und das kann auch
einfach schiefgeht könne gut gehen es
kann schiefgehen wer weiß es ja aber es
gibt ja dann zwei möglichkeiten dagegen
zu argumentieren dass eine ist es gibt
einen verantwortungs überschuss den wir
nie wieder gerecht werden können wir
hier eingreifen und das andere ist es
geht eben auch göttliche gesetze die
sich gerade bei geburt und ende der
existenz besonders stark zeigen und die
haben gar nichts damit um dass wir uns
selbst schaden sondern dass wir es
einfach nicht tun sollten ja ich bin
auch skeptisch gegenüber selbstmord
sowieso wobei ich da was anderes sehe
der abwehr der vertrag gehabt sich über
den tod der ging gar nicht so viel über
über die geburt dass ich natürlich das
ist noch die schönheit die würde und
auch die schrecken der modernen medizin
da sie das unendlich verlängern kann auf
der einen seite profitieren werden
maßlos von der medizin werden alle
vermutlich nicht so alt wie wir jetzt
heute sehen und wenn sie es sie nicht
gäbe aber zugleich ist natürlich das
hinausschieben des todes hat ist
natürlich auch dann erkauft mit einer
lähmenden strecke des des subsidiären
vergleichend des lebens ist auch
schrecklich
und davor haben menschen zu recht angst
ich übrigens auch das heißt also dass da
dede die vorstellung aufkommen dass man
sich vielleicht doch selber rechtzeitig
aus dem leben schaffen muss mit
irgendeiner möglichst gelingt und
methode die verstehe ich sehr gut
sie stört mein weltbild weil ich auch
denke es sollte besser in gottes hand
liegen tatsächlich das möchte ich
eigentlich aber ich bin da wackelig weiß
ich kann da menschen verstehen dass
etwas versuchen sie haben ja eine extrem
aggressive reaktion erfahren man könnte
sagen das war ein shitstorm das war
eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr es war
ein kollektiver aufschrei der empörung
der eine formulierung dass
beispielsweise künstlich gezeugte kinder
für sie wie halb wesen sind die sie gar
nicht als tolle menschen ansehen können
aber es ist ja so auch wenn die
formulierung eine riskante und
vielleicht wie sie es auch selbst sagen
nicht geglückt war
sie haben ein punkt getroffen der ihr
viel im herzen auch berührt nämlich dass
gerade etwas in unserer kultur passiert
dass sie sehr beunruhigt dass wir zu
schöpfen nicht nur unseres eigenen
lebens sondern unsere eigenen leiblichen
existenz werden woher kommt diese
aufschreibe da einfach nur geschrien
weil jeder weiß dass es ein problem ist
oder ist es so dass man da kein tabu
mehr sieht viele jüngere sehen darin
kein tabu mehr das ist eine altersfrage
also ich habe natürlich auch viel
zuspruch bekommen das sind dabei eher
menschen eines etwas gehobeneren
altersjahr die das ähnlich skeptisch
sehen was aber ist vielleicht einfach
natürlichem wege auch kinder hatten
schlicht und ergreifend weiß ich jetzt
nicht so genau
also etwas lockerer und anderes damit
gehen um menschen zusammen zwischen 20
und 40 oder 2030 die das auch häufiger
tun denn sie sind auch er im
gebärfähigen oder überhaupt möglichen
alter dafür dass klar
die sehen das lockerer das ist eine zeit
strom
der natürlich auch mit dem verschwinden
des religiösen auch zu tun hat das heißt
es gibt keine quelle da an einer anderen
haltung oder so die ein mensch zum leben
entwickeln kann indem er bestimmte dinge
die ihm nicht gelingen auch hinnehmen
lernt also wenn wir es nicht gegeben es
auf eigene normalere weise ein kind zu
bekommen muss ich mich entweder damit
abfinden oder sollte vielleicht doch
eins adoptieren es gibt ja immerhin auch
millionen kinder auf der welt im dreieck
verrecken ja weil sich niemand darum
gekümmert
auch das ist für mich sah man auch in
skandale wohlstandsgesellschaft muss man
sich schon sagen also auf der einen
seite haben wir haben wir bitten das
leid von kindern die die keine eltern
mehr haben irgendwie sich durchschlagen
müssen oder auch ganz kleine die idee
und auf der anderen seite wird ist ein
krampfhaftes unternehmen wird da
veranstaltet um irgendwie ein möglichst
eigenes kind zu erzeugen werden
hier seien narzisstische excel genau das
kind das mir zusteht ob man vielleicht
gar keins haben kann
ja ich will das kind und ich will es das
ist noch etwas anderes bei paaren die
wirklich zusammen sind die gibt es ja
nun auch ja wo man sagen kann das ist
eine form der tröstung oder so und sie
wollen sie alles gemeinsam
das ist dann die milde form auf jeden
fall aber es gibt sehr viele frauen gibt
es auf eigenes bestreben hin tun also wo
jetzt der mann kam mit da war ja dafür
und da wird so richtig katastrophal wenn
sie der rechtliche regeln gerne sehen
würden sie das verboten sehen wollen und
sie würden aber schon verstehen dass ein
homosexuelles paar dass jetzt auch die
gegebenen gründen keine kinder zeugen
kann sagen was die lewitscharoff versagt
das ist eigentlich 18 16
wenn wir so argumentieren hätten wir nie
überhaupt eine anerkennung unserer
existenz form erfahren
das stimmt nicht ich bin überhaupt nicht
dagegen dass homosexuelle paare
adoptieren dürfen nein da täuschen sie
sich
es geht mir das ist ja nett oder
hauptproblem der homosexuellen im
übrigen ja also es geht nicht nur um
diese kinder erzeugung homosexuelle wie
homosexualität an sich ist für mich das
sehe ich sehr sehr freiheit ich bin
übrigens mal sehr frei aufgewachsen
meine eltern hatten viel viel
freundinnen und freunde aus dem
homosexuellen bereich also ich bin damit
aufgewachsen also das ist das ist in gar
keiner weise eine wollte gegen
homosexuelle eben homosexualität gewesen
das kommt mir gar nicht in den sinn
und außerdem sie haben ja oft auch
homosexuelle paare egal ob es um
männerpaar ist oder ein frauenpaar ist
wo schon ein kind existiert das gibt's
ja auch also ist ja lächerlich dass zu
verweigern also dass das weiter auch in
der gemeinschaft existieren darf und ich
kenne ein homosexuelles paar wo man sehr
glücklich darüber sein kann dass sie ein
kind adoptiert haben also betrifft ihre
skepsis die technische übernahme der
schöpfung sagt ausschließlich nicht die
tatsache der der sexualität an sich wie
menschen leben
und wenn sie sich kinder wünschen wie
das auf andere als auf adoptions wegen
oder das oder das sehr ein anderes kind
kümmern dass in der nachbarschaft legal
ja das finde ich toll
man könnte ja sagen unser tipp das
sagten sie selber warum hier die grenze
ziehen dürfen ja die kinder wenn sie
zwei monate als zwei monate alt sind
auch wir geben ihnen gewisse dinge ist
ist da einer heiligkeit vermutung bei
ihnen im schöpfungsakt dann letztlich
doch nur religiöse einzuholen wäre
sie hat aber zwei seiten also machen wir
noch mal ein anderes beispiel also da da
dam
heutzutage werden ja mütter fast mit der
schrecklichen frage bedrängt wenn sie
ein behindertes kind zur welt gebracht
haben und sich auch dafür entschieden
haben das hat vielleicht vorher sogar
wussten werden sie hat es denn sein
müssen
verstehen sie dahin dahinter ist auch
eine der unmenschlichkeit verbirgt sich
dahinter die mit die macht mir daran zu
schaffen das ist nicht so sehr dass das
gott ist da nicht der hauptakteur in
meinem hirn was das angeht sondern ich
habe angst davor nicht selber aber ich
denke die verantwortungs lasst die
menschen aufgebürdet wird wenn sie allzu
vieles machbar halten und das abweichen
von der norm eigentlich nicht mehr
akzeptieren können ein behindertes kind
jetzt das sofort im gange da müssen sie
sehr sehr viel tun ihr leben ist auf
einen schlag ein völlig anderes
oder gibt ja viele unwägbarkeiten oder
wenn ein anderes kind vielleicht auch
stirbt oder so das kann alles passieren
verdammt noch mal
das heißt also dass das etwas
ungeschützte hre bei dem was was ich das
im leben dann ereignet per zufall auch
das finde ich irgendwie doch wesentlich
im wesentlichen bei klang des menschen
dass er nicht für jedes und jedes
fitzelchen im leben verantwortlich ist
das ist eine erlösung in höhe sei dank
bin ich dafür nicht verantwortlich kann
man sich dann sagen was für mich sein
beobachter der debatte besonders
irritierend war das eine
schriftstellerin ein mensch des wortes
ja geradezu aufgefordert ist riskant zu
formulieren anders zu sprechen neue
perspektiven einzubringen und bei ihnen
war zu beobachten dass es gerade diese
neuen perspektiven und dieses andere
sprechen unglaublich stark sanktioniert
wurde was man vielleicht zu der
beobachtung schärfen kann dass wir
überhaupt gar nicht in der lage sind
derzeit wirklich abweichende meinungen
anders zu behandeln als mit der
skandalisierung dieser meinung
das passiert so schnell ist aber auch
anderen leuten passiert es ist lotto tag
passiert es ist mosebach passiert das
geht er sehr schnell und oder vielen
vielen anderen das ist ja nun nicht
irgendwie die einzige zwetschke also was
ihre fahren ist deswegen wird die
aussagen nicht so schlimm also ich trage
das oder absagen sagt vorbei eher gering
aber sie versprechen ein wichtiges thema
an und das ist die rhetorik
das heißt wir sind mittlerweile auf so
absurde weise der politische correctness
im sprechen und schreiben sind wir
ausgeliefert dass das treibt ja immer
absurdere blüten und das ist ja an der
universität ist es ja nicht mehr zu
fassen und welche bürokratischen
wortungetüme geschlechter neutral
doppelpass und irgendwie da auf sie
zugewandert kommen das ist ja wirklich
sprachstil der ist ja unter aller kanone
kann man sagen ja also ich hab selber
immer zeit studiert mit vielen frauen
und wir haben uns nie beleidigt gefühlt
das wir studenten waren jetzt wir waren
eben nicht studieren
also da ist ein quatsch im umlauf auch
und es hat mit mit der befreiung gar
nichts mehr zu tun das ist einfach ein
bürokratisches selbstläufer das sind zum
beispiel dinge die ich entsetzlich finde
ja und die haben aber auch damit zu tun
hat mit dedizierten diese themen sind
ein bisschen verschränkt in allem eher
aber gerade jemand der so sensibles
versprach und weiß was namen was
begriffe einzelne individuen antun
können der müsste doch eigentlich auch
eine sensibilität dafür haben zu sagen
dieser begriff tut mir etwas an dieser
begriff lässt mich aus der schafft mir
keine rechte die ich eigentlich hätte ja
in meiner rede ist es vorgekommen also
da habe ich mir ich habe wirklich klar
es waren vier sätze wohl auch denke
nachher dachte hast du noch alle tassen
im schrank ja das heißt du kannst ja
nicht die beleidigen die nun auf der
welt sind die können ja überhaupt nichts
dafür
also da da glaube ich aber jetzt einfach
sagen aber ein bisschen vorfreude die
amish gesprochen da hat doch gynäkologe
als vater in mir mit gesprochener auf
unheimliche weise aber diese politiker
correctness wie sie sagen deren beklagen
sehen sie die derzeitigen entwicklung in
deutschland aber vielleicht amerika oder
in frankreich als funktion als gegen
aggression gegen diese normativen
zumutungen eines allzu korrekten
verengten sprechen natürlich also dass
das hat die schreckliche seite also auch
die politiker sprachen die normal also
die in demokratien noch geläufig sind
bisher die erzeugen natürlich den
totalen gegendruck das heißt also auf
der rechten seite lässt man total die
sau raus ja da ist ansprechend im gang
das ist wirklich menschenverachtend und
zwar aus tiefster seele ja da werden
wirklich begriffe benutzt unter werden
mit dem wo kurz davor ist diesen
menschen zu töten dass das nämlich nicht
einfach hin ja aber das kommt natürlich
auch diese diese eskalation auf der
anderen seite weil die demokratische
seite sommer die akademiker die die was
weiß ich die politiker die ständig
sprechen oder an kulturschaffende und
die sind natürlich einer solchen
beispielen rhetorik mittlerweile
ausgeliefert haben sich der selbst
unterzogen dass sie das andere
zu eigentlich ihnen direkt provozieren
verstehen sie mich ist immer ist immer
nur beste beispiel also denken sie an
herbert wehner und franz josef strauß in
deutschland die wären heute unmöglich in
einem parlament ja die reden doch alle
er selbst politik und die schätze die
reden doch relativ häufig daher auch
wenn sie irgend gegen etwas sind dann
ist es ein bisschen hysterisch oder so
aber diese diese wortgewaltig mit dem
gegner wirklich also jetzt nehme ich
dich bei der besteuerung und fangen an
irgendwie so die hand drauf und die das
ist nicht entschuldigen das ist nicht
rechtsradikal person
nein das ist dass es an also in ein frei
halten ja sag waren
wie würden sie denn als mensch des
wortes als arbeiterin des wortes was
sagen was wenn sie sagen welche
kulturellen kräfte müssen wir aktivieren
um einerseits dieses feld frei zu halten
und andererseits ist nicht den dunklen
kräften zu überlassen
also freizügigkeit auf jeden fall im
sinne von also direktor darüber sprechen
auch mit den leuten sprechen unbedingt
das heißt also viele die ja ich kann es
nur für deutschland seien in der schweiz
kenne ich mich da zu wenig aus natürlich
aber viele die da jetzt so wahnsinnig
aggressiv sind auch geworden sind gegen
die flüchtlingsflut aktuelle oder gerne
ja die leute die da zu uns gekommen sind
ich gehöre dann nicht dazu das ist ganz
klar die haben natürlich auch das sind
auch oft leute diese aber mal ein
bisschen absteigende mittelschicht oder
oder oder oder sozialschichten die sich
eher unten befinden
die haben auch die größten probleme
damit verdammt noch mal das darf man
nicht ganz
wegschaffen ja das heißt es ist genauso
wie trump in amerika das ist genau das
gleiche problem man hat bestimmte
schichten fühlen sich abgehängt die sind
haben auch wirklich verloren in den
letzten 20 jahren also wenn sie in
deutschland kann sie können sehr
sozialgefüge ist ganz klar das war nach
dem krieg wo alles durcheinander schwamm
bahn die sozialstationen sehr viel mehr
geöffnet als es später war das ist ja
eine gebackene gesellschaft die sich
dann immer so ab bewegen und in dem maße
leute die die sich zurecht finde ich auf
der verliererseite auch sehen ja dass
stirbt doch unglaubliche aggressionen
wenn die merken
denen wird überall geholfen die werden
aufgesammelt und die kombinations- und
da ist doch die angst auch groß sie sind
ja in einer zeit groß geworden an dem
man noch in der man noch an die kraft
der literatur glaubte auch als
gesellschaftlich prägen da klappt
glauben sie in der jetzigen situation
die literatur als literatur hat einen
einsatz hat eine wirkung in dieser
situation nein glaube ich nicht naja
also nicht nein direkt nicht das ist
schon ein zumal ich doch mühe damit habe
das literatur immer sofort verwertet das
ist nicht so ganz günstig also dass das
literatur beeinflusst werden muss von
zeitströmungen ist vollkommen klar also
wir können nicht irgendwie rum schreiben
als würden wir gemütlich sagen wir mal
1870 irgendwie auf dem sofa sitzen mit
viel sprudel warum ist da ja aber aber
die die immer die direkte übernahme des
politischen
das hat schon einen haken das würde ich
doch gerne dem gefehlt des journalismus
und politik wirklich überlassen also ist
die der einsatz der literatur wenn ich
verstehe immer ein indirekter und
niemals ein direkter für die kultur ein
indirekter indem sie an einem würdigen
letztlich doch würdigen menschenbild
festhält das heißt auch figuren die ins
elend gestoßen werden in einem roman
dobel furchtbare sachen gehen müssen
immer noch so erscheinen dass man im
zweifelsfall denkt es ist trotzdem ein
gottgegebenes geschöpft so eine sprache
für die würde des menschen in seiner
gegebenheit zu finden ist ein sehr
schönes schlusswort
von ihnen freude wirtschaft und ich
danke ihnen sehr dass sie heute da waren
vielen dank dann gehen auch nächste
woche spricht mein kollege yves bost
einem world webforum über kreativität
und die frage wie die ideen der zukunft
entstehen und zwar mit zwei ganz
besonderen gästen dem gründer und
präsidenten des erfolgreichen
animationsfilm studios pixar und mit
mary ann gittel die den kreativen geist
des legendären burning man festival von
der wüste in die weite welt hinaus trägt
das sollten sie auf keinen fall
verpassen und jetzt gleich zeigt die
sternstunde kunst ein film über die us
amerikanische fotografin du es ja in
ihrem land half sich selbst besser zu
verstehen
also genießen sie den sonntag wieder
sehen
[Musik]